in the last video you saw what a single
hidden layer neural network looks like
in this video let's go through the
details of exactly how this neural
network computers outputs what you see
is that is like logistic regression but
repeater of all the times let's take a
look so this is what's a two layer
neural network looks let's go more DB
into exactly what this new network
compute now was set before that logistic
regression the circle in logistic
regression really represents two steps
of computation rows you compute Z as
follows and in second you compute the
activation as a sigmoid function of Z so
in your network just does this a lot
more times let's start by focusing on
just one of the nodes in the hidden
layer and let's look at the first node
in the hidden layer so I've grayed out
the other nodes for now so similar to
logistic regression on the left is node
in a hidden layer that's two steps of
computation right the first step and
think of as the left half of this node
it computes Z equals W transpose X plus
B and the notation were used is um these
are all quantities associated with the
first hidden there so that's why we have
a bunch of square brackets there and
this is the first node in the hidden
layer so that's why we have the
subscript one over there so first it
does that and then the second step is it
computes a 1 1 equals say point of Z 1 1
like so so for both Zn a the notational
convention is that on a oh I DL here in
superscript square backers refers to
layer number and the I subscript here
refers to the nodes in that layer so the
node will be looking at is layer 1 that
is a hidden layer node 1 so that's why
the superscript and subscript were on
both 1 1 so that little circle that
first node in a neural network
represents carrying out these two steps
of computation now let's look at the
second node in your network the second
node in a hidden layer comes in your
network similar to the logistic
regression unit on the left this little
circle represents two steps of
computation the first step is a
confusing Z this is still layer 1 the
now is the second note equals W Tron's
x+ v 2 and then a & 2 equals sigmoid of
z12 and again feel free to pause the
video if you want that you can double
check that B superscript and subscript
notation is consistent with what we have
written here above in purple so we'll
talk through the first two hidden units
in the neural network on hidden units 3
& 4 also represents some computations so
now let me take this pair of equations
and this pair of equations and let's
copy them to the next line so here's our
network and here's the first and there's
the second equations they've worked on
previously for the first and the second
hidden units if you then go through and
write out the corresponding equations
for the third and fourth hidden units
you get the following and those make
sure this notation is clear this is the
vector W 1 1 this is a vector transpose
times X so that's what the superscript T
there represents this vector transpose
now as you might have guessed if you're
actually implementing in your network
doing this with a for loop seems really
inefficient so what we're going to do is
take these four equations and vectorize
so I'm going to start by showing how to
compute Z as a vector and it turns out
you could do it as follows let me take
these WS and stack them into a matrix
then you have W 1 1 transpose so that's
a row vector of the column vector
transpose gives you a row vector and W 1
2 transpose W 1 3 transpose of V 1 4
transpose and so this by stacking goes
from for W vectors together you end up
with a matrix so another way to think of
this is that we have for logistic
regression unions there and each of the
logistic regression you know is has a
corresponding parameter vector W and by
stacking those four vectors together you
end up with this 4 by 3 matrix so if you
then take this matrix and multiply it by
your input features x1 x2 x3 you end up
with by our matrix multiplication works
you end up with w1 1 transpose X W 1
this will be 2 1 transpose X
we 1 transpose X wo 1 transpose X and
then now let's not forget the bees so we
now add to this the vector e1 1 b12 b13
in 1/4 so that's basically this then
this gives b11 b12 b13 b14 and so you
see that each of the 4 rows of this
outcome correspond exactly to each of
these 4 rows each of these four
quantities that we had above so in other
words we've just shown that this thing
is therefore equal to V 1 1 V 1 to V 1 V
V 1 core right as defined here and maybe
not surprisingly we're going to call
this whole thing the vector V 1 which is
taken by stacking up these are
individuals of these into a column
vector when we're vectorizing one of the
rules of thumb that might help you
navigate this is that when we have
different nodes in a layer we'll stack
them vertically so that's why when you
have V 1 1 2 0 1 4 those correspond to
four different nodes in the hidden layer
and so we stack these four numbers
vertically to form the vector Z 1 and
reduce one more piece of notation this 4
by 3 matrix here which we obtained by
stacking the lower case you know W 1 1 W
1 2 and so on we're going to call this
matrix W Capital One and similarly this
vector or going to call B superscript 1
square bracket and so this is a four
point one vector so now we've computed Z
using this vector matrix notation the
last thing we need to do is also compute
these values of a and so probably won't
surprise you to see that we're going to
define a 1 as just stacking together
those activation values a11 to a14 so
just take these four values and stack
them together in a vector called
a1 and this is going to be sigmoid of z1
where there's no husband implantation of
the sigmoid function that takes in the
four elements of Z and applies the
sigmoid function element wise to it so
just a
we figured out that Z 1 is equal to w1
times the vector X plus the vector B 1
and a 1 is sigmoid times Z 1 let's just
copy this to the next slide and what we
see is that for the first layer of the
neural network given an input X we have
that Z 1 is equal to W 1 times X plus B
1 and a 1 is Sigma we took Z 1 and the
dimensions of this are 4 by 1 equals
this is a 4 by 3 matrix times a 3 by 1
vector plus a on 4 by 1 vector B and
this is 4 by 1 same dimensions and
remember that we said X is equal to a 0
right just like Y hat is also equal to a
2 so if you want you can actually take
this X and replace it with a 0 since a 0
is if you want it as an alias for the
vector of input features X now through a
similar derivation you can figure out
that the representation for the next
layer can also be written similarly
where what the output layer does is it
has associated with it so the parameters
W 2 and B 2 so W 2 in this case is going
to be a 1 by 4 matrix and B 2 is just a
real number as 1 by 1 and so V 2 is
going to be a real numbers right as a 1
by 1 matrix is going to be a 1 by 4
thing times a was 4 by 1 plus B 2 is 1
by 1 and so this gives you just a real
number and if you think of this loss
output unit as just being analogous to
logistic regression which had parameters
W and B W really plays in lagless real
to W 2 transpose or W 2's really W
transpose and B is equal to V 2 right
said were to you know cover up the left
of this network and ignore all that for
now then this is just this last output
unit is a lot like logistic regression
except that instead of writing the
parameters as WMV we're writing them as
W 2 and V 2 with dimensions one by four
and one by one so just a recap for
logistic regression to implement the
output or the influence prediction you
compute Z equals W transpose X plus B
and a y hat equals a equals sigmoid of z
when you have a new network with one
hidden layer what you need to implement
two computers output is just these four
equations and you can think of this as a
vectorized implementation of computing
the output of first these for logistic
regression units in the hidden layer
that's what this does and then this
which is regression in the output layer
which is what this does
I hope this description made sense but
takeaway is to compute the output of
this neural network all you need is
those four lines of code so now you've
seen how given a single input feature
vector at you can with four lines of
code compute the outputs of this new
network um similar to what we did for
the gist regression will also want to
vectorize across multiple training
examples and we'll see that by stacking
up training examples in different
columns in the matrix or just slight
modification to this you also similar to
what you saw in which is regression be
able to compute the output of this
neural network not just on one example
at a time belong your say your entire
inning set at a time so let's see the
details of that in the next video